[Music]
how are you Leila I'm fine
how are you loads of people people
invading my house expecting me to act
like them parties on my worst nightmare
my headphones dead everything sounds
everywhere now people also don't wanna
talk to them people would be correct
sounds now mixing together spinning out
spinning in all around me tangled tinny
tumble sorry famous brain is processing
please leave a message after the tone
leave what are you talking about I want
to do this for mum I don't know if I can
they don't like it but it helps me feel
calm here comes the invasion how to play
smiling don't stare remember the five
things
look all that food touching other food
put biscuits really be friends with a
pasta salad maybe this is why I don't
fit in
I'm the biscuit they're the salad we
don't belong on the same plate I'm fine
here thanks maybe young people don't
seem to like them very much
am i staring
I literally no idea of what my face is
doing no what does everyone else know
how to act I wish I could have come in
fancy dress then I wouldn't have to be
here as me
I'm not deaf you know you're invisible
you'll always think special to me I
don't know why we give people Labor's
everyone makes such a fuss of these
things don't they
but you're just you know unique make it
go away focus on some things I can do
this
no it's so happening
the champagne I can't move I'll never
get through all of them need to keep
calm remember the exercise
five things I can see what things I can
touch things like in here
whoa I know
I'll pile meat out
five things and I
nice things by touch hey you can't see
you
how're you doing right some cake I
ruined it tonight
my waste room things I think Dad got a
bit carried away there you know it's
like I don't think he realized how hard
it would be for you
but you know what it's gonna get easier
for us to help you now now that we know
no more surprises it's a deal
happy birthday mom oh thank you darling
you take as long as you
[Music]
at least mum gets it
I wish it could be easier but it's
exhausting I'll be recovering from this
for days I want to fit in but sometimes
I need to fit myself out
just leave escape I'm here where I need
to be where it's safe
it'll be okay
and maybe sometime in the future it'll
be Xia
[Music]
I don't think you didn't know and I was
autistic until you put me in a birthday
pie setting
[Music]
I practice conversations so I practice
what they might say to me how it
introduce myself or how if they
introduced themselves what I'd say I
consider facial expressions before I
make them because a lot of its
practicing being your typical when I'm
anxious my brain flashes things at me
like really fast my head will go will
fizzy kind of like when you're in a tube
stop and you know when the tube goes
past really quickly it's kind of like
that he seems to build up and up and up
and then it's like you can hear
everything you know you can hear it in
seems like it's in layers and it's so
overwhelming I just go into shutdown and
just just wouldn't be able to do
anything if I was that tired from a
social scenario I would literally just
have to crawl under the duvet and put
stuff on it you know you try really hard
to come across as being very typical and
then it just means people don't realize
that you actually do struggle with
things